So let me set up this next segment for you.
I already told you Chris Wallace was likely
onstage with a contagious Trump during Tuesday's
debate based on the timeline.
We understand that in all likelihood, Donald
Trump contracted Corona virus either sometime
between Saturday and Monday of the previous
week and was likely contagious during the
debate.
As I already told you, Donald Trump was not
tested at the debate.
As most people, as everybody was supposed
to be, they showed up late and were allowed
to use the honor system to tell them Trump
doesn't have Corona virus.
I already told you last week during a stream
that Donald Trump's family immediately took
off their masks at the debate.
The only people in the debate hall to do so,
even though the rules were keep the masks
on.
So this weekend, CNN, Fox News, Sunday, you
know, all of these different Sunday shows,
they tried to get Trump administration people
on to talk about what's going on.
No one agreed to do it except one senior adviser
to Trump named Steve Cortez, who went on Fox
News Sunday with Chris Wallace.
And it devolved into base utter lunacy that
we really should be studying and teaching
our children so they don't grow up to be like
Steve Cortez.
Let's start with Chris Wallace asking, why
doesn't the Trump family think the rules apply
to them with the masks?
And Cortez is immediately being deceptive,
not apply to them?
No, that's not the reality.
Look, everybody was tested before that event.
As you well know, those of us who went first
were tested by Cleveland kind of directly.
Everybody who gets on Air Force One for any
trip on Air Force One is tested before they
get on to a different matter.
It doesn't matter.
Everybody that was in that room was tense.
Steve, everybody that was in that room was
tested and the Cleveland Clinic regulation
was it didn't matter.
Everybody, except for the three of us on the
stage was to wear a mask.
And people from the Cleveland Clinic came
over and offered the first family mask, thinking
maybe they didn't have them.
They were waved away.
And the Commission on Presidential Debates
has issued a statement saying, from now on,
if you don't wear a mask, you're going to
be escorted from the hall.
So Chris Wallace is rightly upset there because
he and Biden may have been exposed at the
debate.
But when Cortez says, listen, everybody on
Air Force One is tested, remember, Trump showed
up too late to be tested and they took Trump's
word that he was negative.
And now we know Trump may well have been positive
at the time and was almost certainly contagious,
according to multiple doctors, even on the
basic facts.
This Trump adviser.
Not known about camp, but won't be honest.
Let's continue.
So forget this question of being right beforehand.
Everybody was tested beforehand, but no, I'm
going to finish my question.
Everybody was told to wear a mask.
Why did the first family and the chief of
staff feel that the rules for everybody else
didn't apply to them?
Chris, we believe the mass are very useful.
The president has worn them on many occasions,
including visiting the hospital where he is
now a patient when he was visiting as commander
in chief, as a guest to visit soldiers there,
he wore a mask.
We believe in mass.
We also believe in some element of individual
choice.
People were distanced and they had been tested.
This is all, you know, me, me, me.
We believe in choice.
We believe in masks.
Those aren't the questions.
The question is, the debate hall had rules
wide.
Why did the Trump family just ignore them?
Now, there is shared blame here.
The first family should have been kicked out.
And it was the debate organizers and the venue
that didn't do it.
And I understand that that's a difficult thing
to do, would have had major PR repercussions
despite being the right thing to do.
Now, the debate commission has been forced
to say if there are future debates at this
point, we don't know.
Trump has coronavirus.
If you don't wear a mask, you are going to
be kicked out.
But the guy simply can't answer a simple question.
Now, notice what happens next when Steve Cortez
can't get away from the question.
Why did they break the rules?
He switches to attacking Chris Wallace.
Both of those things were true in that actually
they weren't just understand there were rules
and there was no there was no freedom of choice.
They broke through.
I was there.
They're like, how are they doing this?
Why does Eric not all of us together.
Look, those chairs were not close together.
And again, we also believe that Pete doesn't
matter.
Space liberals from the worked close together,
Steve.
And the rules in the Cleveland Clinic where
everybody wears a mask.
Why didn't Chris.
Chris, the way you're starting to harangue
me now, Ashleigh, reminds me what you did
to the president during that debate on Tuesday
night when he was just trying town.
No.
Did you see what he did there?
He goes after Chris Wallace.
He says, listen, Chris, you're haranguing
me just like you did to Trump.
You unfair moderator from Fox News.
Of course, when you lose on the facts, you
go ad hominem.
This is a very typical thing that happens
in debates when people lose on the facts.
And it continues.
And Chris Wallace just read it starts reaming
out Steve Cortez.
And then he had to he had to debate not just
Joe Joe Biden, but you as well.
You are not a neutral moderator then.
I don't mind tough questions.
I welcome no reason to be too cautious.
But what I don't think is OK is for you to
become the effective opposition to the president.
OK.
And those everyone there was tested in the
crowd.
They were distance from each other.
People can make reasonable decisions for themselves
straight.
No, they actually that can't.
They're the rules and they'll be kicked out
next time.
Steve, let me just simply say, the president
interrupted me and the vice president one
hundred and forty five times.
So I object to saying I harangue the president.
I know what's the talking point?
So the problem is that while Wallace Wallace
says it's true, Trump did interrupt more than
100 times.
This is actually about the rules of the debate
hall.
It's not what Don Junior's assessment of the
distance between chairs is.
That doesn't matter.
And unfortunately, Trump will fall for this
when you ask Trump lists.
I haven't seen it done yet, but based on the
vigil they held with no masks outside Walter
Reed over the weekend, if you went to Trump's
and you said, what about this?
Why did the Trump family pull that?
You know, it's wrong.
They took their mask off.
They would say there was lots of space and
we believe in masks when people are crowded
together, but they weren't crowded to get
it together.
The people who claim to be all about law and
order are going to say, well, you know the
rules.
We decide if we want to follow the rules or
if the rules make sense or whatever.
Doesn't really sound like law and order to
me.
I assure you they see this and they end up
mad at Chris Wallace, not at dishonest Steve
Cortez, the lying Trump adviser, not at the
Trump family for not wearing masks, not at
Trump for making fun of Joe Biden's mask while
likely contagious with Corona virus himself
while on the stage.
Now, the practical question is whether there
will be more debates this week.
Wednesday night is the Kamala Harris versus
Mike Pence V.P. debate.
Every indication is that's going to happen,
although they've agreed to more space between
Harris and Pence on the stage.
I would love to see Kamala Harris bring her
own plexiglass.
Mike Pence was at the Amy CONI Barrett super
spreader event sitting next to people who
got the virus.
I would be careful if I was Kamala Harris.
Then we get to the debates, number two and
three for Trump and Biden.
Now, the first one is scheduled for 10 days
from today.
Trump has corona virus.
As of today, that that's what we know.
You know what they claim tomorrow?
I don't know.
But at least as of today, Trump has corona
virus.
Trump's going to travel in 10 days or even
nine days if he's supposed to go the day of.
More to a debate on an airplane and again,
be onstage with Joe Biden and the moderator
just 10 days after being in the hospital for
coronavirus.
I don't see it.
So I don't know if the idea is maybe they
will go remote.
I don't know what the thought is at this point.
There may be no more debate debates.
They may be video conference debates.
Maybe the second one gets canceled and they
skip to the third, which is an additional
week down the line, 17 days from today.
It's anyone's guess at this point in time.
We'll follow it and let you know as we learn
more about it.